this small islet in Spain is connected
to the mainland by a narrow man-made
path and fans of game of turns might
recognize it as the ancestral home to
the mother of dragons
Godzilla gotcha
can be found in Basque Country in Spain
and is home to a small chapel that is
dedicated to John the Baptist the narrow
stone bridge that connects the islet
consists of 231 zigzagging steps leading
up to the chapel legend has it that if
visitors make it to the top and ring the
bell on the exterior three times a wish
will be granted a structure was first
built on the island in the 9th century
however since then it has been destroyed
rebuilt and changed purposes many times
its uses have ranged from a convent to
serving as a site of imprisonment for
accused witches during the Spanish
Inquisition in season 7 of Game of
Thrones the stairwell made an appearance
is Dragonstone causing its popularity to
skyrocket thousands of visitors flocked
to this recognizable location for its
beauty or perhaps simply in hopes of one
day catching themselves a glimpse of
Daenerys Targaryen
you